Blake asks how important is it that your
significant other share your
entrepreneurial vision what was Lizzy's
impact on building your empire Blake
this is a great question I excited to
get your question on the show um you
know first of all Lizzy's impact on my
career is much more than I expected you
know I grew up and would hear things
like behind every great man is a great
woman I'd be like and not in a negative
like chauvinistic way but like I was
like I'm hustling my face off like I'd
be working every hour and then you start
growing and you mature and and you
become a man not a kid and the truth is
I'm actually flabbergasted by the level
of Liz's impact on my career Lizzie's
kind of support and I mean like utter
100,000% support is like a major factor
it gives me the headspace to be all in
here at Vayner and doing my thing versus
worrying about like if I'm five minutes
late you know I'm running late taping
this right now if I get home like it's
you know it's incredibly important in
the fact if you prioritize your career
curveball you know so it's massively
important to give you headspace to have
you know as much freedom to execute on
your vision professionally but the truth
is when you fall in love with somebody
that person needs to take you know
precedent over everything else and so at
some level if you don't have that well
you know that just comes with the
consequences of love and and and that's
okay too you may not be able to hustle
or work on it or work on it in a clear
mind space and never give it a hundred
percent I'm able to give 100 percent
devotion to my businesses for enormous
amounts of time every day because of
Lizzie and the way she rules and
supports some people can only put 73
percent of their time for a shorter
period of time and they're going to have
limited success in comparison predicated
on our talent as well because talent is
a variable so it's massively important
for success but it's not the only thing
is it